[Music]
for decades
researchers have been devising new ways
to explore
the deep ocean and now a team of
roboticists
have taken inspiration from the weird
and wonderful creatures they found there
to build a new
type of soft explorer
this pliable box gently flies untethered
through the deep
its soft structure is designed to tackle
the greatest engineering challenge
facing those who want to explore the
depths pressure
most deep sea machines cope using super
strong
rigid materials or pressure compensation
systems
but these approaches can be bulky and
heavy
and if they fail it can be catastrophic
the researchers argue that a soft robot
could be a promising alternative
flexible materials could shift and
squish rather than break under the
pressure
with a lower risk of massive failure
almost everything on this robot is soft
even the motor powering the gentle
flapping is a soft disc
which contracts in response to
electrical impulses
sort of like an artificial muscle
but even soft robots require controls
and power on board to operate remotely
and without bulky protection the
electronics themselves
don't always cope that well under
pressure
to solve this problem research has
turned to evolution
in particular the mariana snailfish
this soft and ghostly creature is the
deepest living fish
ever discovered ct scans revealed it has
an intriguing skeletal structure
unlike most fish the snailfish's skull
is open
and somewhat distributed throughout its
head it's thought that this structure
helps the fish cope with pressure
and that got the robot designers
thinking
they hypothesized that distributing the
vulnerable electronics
could also decrease the stress on each
part
the team modeled the impacts of
separating the battery and part of the
control
architecture and it seemed that this
could indeed reduce the stress on the
interfaces between the components
the next step was to build and test it
the robot performed well in a
pressurized chamber in the lab
first swimming in a circle then free
swimming
to get a sense of how much pressure the
chamber is under
look at the green foam cylinder at
atmospheric pressures
it is six centimeters across but her
pressures mimicking the deep
ocean it's crushed to less than 1.5
centimeters the lab experiments were
promising
but the real test would come when they
took it out into the wild
first a lake where it took its first
swims in open water performing well
down to about 70 meters
next they used a conventional remote
operated vehicle
to take the bot more than three
kilometers down in the south china sea
and it kept on swimming but to really
put it through its paces
they needed to travel to the deepest
place on the planet
the mariana trench the robot was mounted
on a deep sea lander and dropped to a
depth of almost 11 kilometers
the pressure down here is the equivalent
of a human holding
50 jumbo jets on their back
although it wasn't allowed to swim
freely here the little bot
flapped away for 45 minutes functioning
perfectly
despite the crushing pressures now as it
stands the robot is slow
simple and not especially maneuverable
but the researchers see it as a proof of
principle
they say that you could add other
distributed electronics like sensors
which could make the robot smarter
and new designs could make it more
powerful or versatile
time will tell but who knows maybe the
future of hardened
deep sea exploration will be
well soft